I wrote programs in notebooks and executed them in my head. God damn, you're Bill Gates. And made fairly significant money for ninth graders. My two top computers that I was looking at were the Ohio Scientific Challenger and the Exitie Sorcerer. There was a lot of Apple II software that appeared in this time frame that had stamped on it cracked by Serpent and Serpent was my initials are SRP so it was SRP-E-N-T so Serpent was me
我在笔记本上写程序，然后在脑子里运行它们。天哪，你简直就是比尔·盖茨。而且对于九年级的学生来说，赚的钱相当可观。我当时关注的两台顶级计算机是 Ohio Scientific Challenger 和 Exidy Sorcerer。那个时期出现了很多 Apple II 软件，上面印着“由 Serpent 破解”，Serpent 是我的名字缩写，我的名字缩写是 SRP，所以是 SRP-E-N-T，Serpent 就是我。
A computer class with no computers is Yeah and we spent like the next 72 hours Writing code on a Mac Plus and 68K assembly language With no docs and just a debugger to figure out API calls Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 263 recorded on October 10th, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue our chaotic conversation with Sean Parent and get the origin story pre-adobe, pre-apple, and pre-orange micro. and find out where Sean Parent came from.
一个没有电脑的计算机课，是的，我们花了接下来大约 72 小时在 Mac Plus 上用 68K 汇编语言写代码，没有文档，只有一个调试器来弄清楚 API 调用。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 263 集，录制于 2025 年 10 月 10 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们继续与 Sean Parent 进行混乱的对话，了解他在 Adobe、Apple 和 Orange Micro 之前的故事，并找出 Sean Parent 的起源。
I mean, I'm thinking that you, Connor, you will be the official Sean Parent biographer. Well, AI will be the ghost writer. All right, we just heard some amazing stories from Sean about childhood crimes that maybe we'll get him to retail sometime. But we were, Connor was just asking Sean, on how he went from living in rural Washington to programming, right?
我的意思是，我在想，Connor，你将成为 Sean Parent 的官方传记作者。好吧，人工智能将成为代笔者。好了，我们刚刚听到了 Sean 关于童年犯罪的一些惊人故事，也许我们以后会让他再讲一遍。但是我们，Connor 刚才在问 Sean，他是如何从住在华盛顿农村到开始编程的，对吧？
Because you grew up in a fairly rural area. So you might have to rewind through four minutes. Okay, so rewinding. So I had a seventh grade math teacher who was a NASA engineer before she decided to become a math teacher. and it was kind of an accelerated math program. And she had the policy that if we could come in in the morning for class
因为你在一个相当偏远的地区长大。所以你可能得倒带四分钟。好的，倒带。我有一位七年级的数学老师，她在决定成为数学老师之前是 NASA 的工程师。那是一个加速数学课程。她有一个规定，如果我们能在早上来上课时，
and ask a question related to mathematics and current events. So it had to be something we found in a magazine or a newspaper or something like that and ask her to explain it, then she would spend the time explaining the math behind it in answering our question. It specifically had to be related to current events. It specifically had to be related to current events. And as long as we could feed her questions and keep her answering, we didn't have to open the textbook and do assignments.
提出一个与数学和时事相关的问题。所以它必须是我们从杂志、报纸或其他类似东西中发现的，并请她解释，然后她会花时间解释背后的数学原理来回答我们的问题。它必须专门与时事相关。它必须专门与时事相关。只要我们能不断向她提问并让她回答，我们就不必打开课本做作业。
And it was pretty incredible because we would come up with, you know. By we, you mean you. It wasn't just me. There were a number of us. So we would come up with questions, and we wouldn't always succeed in keeping her busy for the whole hour. But we would ask questions, and she would cover things and explain them in seventh grade terms, and it would include explanations of statistics and calculus and whatever was necessary to solve that problem. And she did an outstanding job at kind of breaking it down to a level we could grasp.
这真是太不可思议了，因为我们会想出，你知道的。你说“我们”，是指你。不仅仅是我。我们有好几个人。所以我们会想出问题，虽然我们并不总能成功地让她忙上一整小时。但我们会问问题，她会涵盖这些内容并用七年级的术语来解释，其中包括统计学、微积分以及解决该问题所需的任何知识。她出色地将这些知识分解到了我们能理解的水平。
And explain like I'm in grade seven. Yeah, yeah. And so that kind of laid my, my mathematics background and interest. And through that, I saw the relevance of math. What was her name? Her name was Ella Mae Knowles. I remember the name. And it was great when I did not graduate from high school.
就像我还在七年级一样解释。是的，是的。这奠定了我的数学背景和兴趣。通过这些，我看到了数学的相关性。她叫什么名字？她叫 Ella Mae Knowles。我记得这个名字。当我没有从高中毕业时，这真是太棒了。
We'll get there, I guess. But I did it. attend my class's high school graduation, and she also came. So that was the last time I saw her was at what would have been my high school graduation. Do you think she kept tabs on you? I have no idea, so she hasn't kept in touch. I've tried to look her up and Google her a couple times, but haven't found her, so I don't know if she got married or remarried or what. Maybe the listeners will know LMA Know's ex-NASA engineer. So specifically, I believe she worked on space suits for women at NASA. So in any case, that sparked a strong interest in math. And, you know, I had
我想我们会讲到那里的。但我确实参加了我班的高中毕业典礼，她也来了。所以那是我最后一次见到她，是在我本该高中毕业的时候。你觉得她一直关注着你吗？我不知道，她没有保持联系。我试过几次在谷歌上搜索她，但没找到，所以我不知道她是否结婚或再婚了，或者发生了什么。也许听众会知道 LMA Knowles，前 NASA 工程师。据我所知，她曾在 NASA 从事女性宇航服的工作。总之，这激发了我对数学的浓厚兴趣。而且，你知道，我
some skills in math, I guess, which is why it was in her class before that. But that was really where I saw the relevance of math and really got interested in it. And then the same year that this is going on, my dad worked at Boeing, and they offered a programming class in basics. to Boeing employees and it was like an evening class and my dad signed up for it but not enough people signed up to take the course
有一些数学技能，我想，这就是为什么在那之前我会在她的班上。但那确实是我看到数学的相关性并真正对它产生兴趣的地方。就在同一年，我父亲在波音公司工作，他们为波音员工提供了一门基础编程课程，那是一门夜校课程，我父亲报名了，但报名参加这门课程的人数不够，
so they opened it up to family members of Boeing employees so my dad asked me if I wanted to take a course on basic programming and so this would have been I don't know late 70s time frame maybe like 77 I had never touched a computer
所以他们向波音员工的家属开放了。所以我父亲问我想不想参加基础编程课程，这大概是，我不知道，70 年代末，可能是 77 年左右。我从来没碰过电脑，
never seen one in person you know to me a computer was a big things with reel-to-reel tapes that you saw on TV and lots of flashing lights, right? So I thought this was pretty exciting that it would get to go take the class. And so went and took the course, and it was 100% lecture, no hands-on, never saw a computer for the entire course. The best way to learn. The best way to learn.
从来没亲眼见过，你知道，对我来说，电脑是电视上看到的带有卷对卷磁带和闪烁灯光的大东西，对吧？所以我认为能去上这门课非常令人兴奋。于是我去上了这门课，它是 100% 的讲座，没有实践，整个课程中从未见过电脑。学习的最佳方式。学习的最佳方式。
but got handouts on basic programming, and I was, I don't know, completely obsessed with this idea that somewhere there were these machines, that you would give them instructions, and these machines would follow the instructions, and now I knew how to give them instructions. And I had handouts with instructions on how to give the machine instructions. And so I wrote programs in notebooks and executed them in my head. God damn, you're Bill Gates. I just, we interviewed, I can't remember who, we interviewed on a Raycast, and he mentioned all of, I can't remember the guest. I mean, I definitely remember the conversation. And he mentioned Bill Gates' first part of his two-part or three-part biography called Source Code. Can't recommend it highly enough.
但我得到了基础编程的讲义，我不知道，完全沉迷于这样一个想法：在某个地方有这些机器，你给它们指令，这些机器就会遵循指令，现在我知道如何给它们指令了。我手里有关于如何给机器下达指令的讲义。所以我把程序写在笔记本上，然后在脑子里运行它们。天哪，你简直就是比尔·盖茨。我只是，我们采访过，我不记得是谁了，我们在 Raycast 上采访过，他提到了所有，我不记得那位嘉宾了。我的意思是，我肯定记得那次谈话。他提到了比尔·盖茨那本三部曲传记的第一部分，叫《源代码》。强烈推荐。
But at some point in the book, he talks about these hikes. He was a part of some Boy Scouts, they would go on these massive hikes. And he would program in his head and then get back and have solved some problem. You're basically Bill Gates. And also, it's uncanny, these, you know, all the greats of computer science lore. They had access to a parent that was a prof that had one of the first, whatever. I've never heard the parent that was at Boeing that was offered a course, and then family members were invited.
但在书中的某个地方，他谈到了这些徒步旅行。他是童子军的一员，他们会进行大规模的徒步旅行。他会在脑子里编程，然后回来就解决了某个问题。你基本上就是比尔·盖茨。而且，这太不可思议了，你知道，所有计算机科学传说中的伟人。他们都有机会接触到一位是教授的父母，拥有第一台什么的。我从来没听说过父母在波音公司，然后被邀请参加课程的。
But that is an alternative version of these kind of. You had to have exposure early on to... What is it with everybody in C++ having started off with Basic? I mean, me, you, like, just dozens of people. I don't know. It was basic that, yeah. It is a basic, but it's not the basic. Yeah.
但这是一种替代版本。你必须很早就接触到……为什么每个 C++ 程序员都是从 Basic 开始的？我的意思是，我，你，就像，几十个人。我不知道。是 Basic，是的。它是 Basic，但不是那种 Basic。是的。
Yeah. I wrote programs and notebooks and executed them in my head and did that until ninth grade. And then how many, how many years is that? Two years. So, like, two years. You're just, you're compiling and executing. Yeah. And then.
是的。我把程序写在笔记本上，然后在脑子里运行，一直做到九年级。那是多少年？两年。所以，大约两年。你只是在编译和执行。是的。然后。
Somebody... That's how to be successful, folks. If you're struggling to find a job, just spend two years. Yep. So 9th grade, somebody donates one of the original TRS80s to our junior high. So our junior high was 7th, 8th, and 9th grade. And so I'm in 9th grade. Somebody donate to TRS 80.
有人……这就是成功之道，伙计们。如果你在找工作时遇到困难，只需花两年时间。是的。所以九年级时，有人向我们的初中捐赠了一台最初的 TRS80。所以我们的初中是七、八、九年级。所以我当时在九年级。有人捐赠了一台 TRS 80。
And the faculty has no idea what to do with this. And a friend of mine, he was best man at my wedding, best friend, Mark Matsudaira. He and I find out about this, and we talk to the faculty, and we convinced them that we need access to this computer. You're in grade nine? Grade nine. And you're talking to the faculty of the school? Of the school, yeah, yeah.
教职员工不知道该怎么处理它。我的一个朋友，他是我婚礼上的伴郎，最好的朋友，Mark Matsudaira。我和他发现了这件事，我们和教职员工谈了谈，我们说服他们我们需要使用这台电脑。你当时在九年级？九年级。你在和学校的教职员工谈话？是的，是的。
And we convinced them that we need access to this computer. And so they're like, well, we don't know what to do with it. So they set it up in kind of this large closet. Great, so this is before the gunpowder? This is probably concurrent with the gunpowder. So, different story, which we're not going to cover here, because I don't want FBI showing up at my doorstep. Yeah, we set it up in a closet.
我们说服他们我们需要使用这台电脑。他们说，好吧，我们不知道该怎么处理它。所以他们把它放在了一个大壁橱里。太棒了，这是在火药之前吗？这可能与火药事件同时发生。所以，那是另一个故事，我们不在这里讲，因为我不想让 FBI 出现在我家门口。是的，我们把它放在了一个壁橱里。
Wait, they actually gave you the computer. No, they didn't give us the computer. They set it up in the closet, like, near the front office for the school, and gave us a key, each a key, to this closet. So we could access it after hours, okay? And or during lunch or breaks. And I have a question. When they gave you the key, was the intention that you access it after hours
等等，他们真的把电脑给了你们？不，他们没把电脑给我们。他们把它放在了壁橱里，就在学校前台附近，并给了我们一把钥匙，每人一把，通往这个壁橱。所以我们可以在下班后，或者午餐或休息时间使用它。我有一个问题。当他们给你钥匙时，意图是让你在下班后使用，
or was the intention that you would access it during breaks and during lunch? It was both. It was both. We were allowed to access it. And so, and it was like just at the start of a whole, hallway from the front office. So we were visible, right? We're not going to be doing anything bad in here. So we programmed it. I got to type in some of the programs that I had had written in notebooks. And they worked? They did. Like I got a black check game working. They required, you know,
还是意图是让你在休息和午餐时间使用？两者都有。两者都有。我们被允许使用它。而且它就在前台走廊的尽头。所以我们是可见的，对吧？我们不会在里面做任何坏事。所以我们对它进行了编程。我得以输入一些我在笔记本上写过的程序。它们能运行吗？是的。比如我让一个黑杰克游戏运行起来了。它们需要，你知道，
certainly some amount of editing. It was a slightly different variant of basic. And I was working from memory and notes. But yeah, I got these to work. And then we discovered that the TRS80 had these very primitive kind of block graphics. It was kind of a half a character pixel size graphics. And so we wrote this very simple game that would put a pixel on the bottom row of the screen at a random location and then draw a line from slowly, from either the left or right side of the screen. And if you hit the space bar, it would draw a line down. and if you hit that pixel that was there,
一定程度的编辑。那是 Basic 的一个略有不同的变体。我是凭记忆和笔记工作的。但是的，我让它们运行起来了。然后我们发现 TRS80 有这种非常原始的块状图形。它是一种半字符像素大小的图形。所以我们写了一个非常简单的游戏，它会在屏幕底行的一个随机位置放置一个像素，然后从屏幕的左侧或右侧缓慢地画一条线。如果你按下空格键，它就会画一条线下来。如果你击中了那个像素，
it would kind of do a little explosion of big blocky pixels and you would get a point. And it was a two-player game that we created. So it would then go to the other person's team. The line would start drawing from the other side of the screen. They'd hit the space bar and it would go down and hit. And if it got it, they got a point. And we made it something like, you know, first person to,
它就会产生一个小爆炸，变成大块像素，你就会得一分。这是我们创造的一个双人游戏。然后它会轮到另一个人。线会从屏幕的另一侧开始画。他们按下空格键，它就会下来并击中。如果击中了，他们就得一分。我们把它设定为，你知道，先到 9 分的人赢，因为我们不想写代码来增加另一位数。所以就像先到 9 分的人赢，我们在午餐时间向孩子们收取 25 美分来玩。不是我预想的那样？是的，交易是第一个人，好吧，如果你赢了，你就可以留在游戏中而不用再付 25 美分，而挑战者要付 25 美分。基本上是“山丘之王”。是的。
to, I think it was to 9.1 because we didn't want to write the code to get another another digit in there. So it was like first person to 9-1, and we charged kids a quarter over lunch to play. Not where I saw that going? Yeah, and the deal was the first person, well, if you won, then you got to stay in the game without another quarter, and it cost the challenger the quarter. It's a king of the hell, basically. Yeah.
是的，作为九年级的学生，这样做赚了相当可观的钱。午餐时间我们门口排着队要玩这个游戏。老师们知道吗？是的，老师们知道。他们就像，随便吧，你知道。好企业家。是的，完全正确，完全正确。我在高中时，一些老师，比如，
Yeah, and made fairly significant money for 9th graders doing this. We had to line out the door at lunchtime to play this game. Did the teachers know? Yeah, the teachers knew. Like, they were like, whatever, you know. Good little enterprisers. Yeah, exactly, exactly. When I was in high school, some of the teachers, like,
让我帮忙处理电脑方面的事情，比如如何使用 PowerPoint 之类的，这变得太频繁了，最终我受够了，给校长寄了一张发票，我不记得他们付没付，但我认为他们在那之后就不再找我帮忙了。是的，那是我第一次亲手接触到真正的电脑，并得以使用它，从我出生起我就知道我必须拥有一台电脑。到目前为止，我的父母要求我们每次收到钱，比如圣诞节或生日之类的，任何我们收到的钱，一半都要存入银行账户作为大学学费。所以我有一本存折和一个银行账户，里面大约有 1000 美元。
had me helping out with like computer stuff like how to use PowerPoint and things like that and it got so frequent eventually I got like fed up and sent an invoice to the price principle which I don't recall whether they paid or not but I think they stopped asking me for help after that yeah that was kind of the first time I ever had my hands on an actual computer and got to use one and knew that I had to own a computer from the time I was was born up and this point, my parents required that any time we were given money for, you know, Christmas or birthdays or anything like that. Any money we received, half went into a bank account for college. And so I had a bank book and a bank account and something around $1,000 in my
我的朋友 Mark，我刚才提到的，他爸爸在西雅图市中心有一家男装店，所以偶尔我会搭便车，和 Mark 以及他爸爸去市中心，Mark 和我会在西雅图市中心闲逛一会儿。
bank account. And my friend, Mark, who I just mentioned, his dad had a men's clothing. store in downtown Seattle and so occasionally I would catch a ride I would go with Mark and his dad downtown and Mark and I would hang out in downtown Seattle for a while
离我们住的地方大约 45 分钟路程，西雅图市中心有一家 Wolf Camera 卖电脑。这是哪一年？
and about 45 minutes away from where we lived and there was a wolf camera downtown Seattle that sold computers and what years is this
你告诉我们这是一次关键的旅行，你带着你的……所以这应该是……让我想想。那是 Apple 2 Plus 出来的那一年，所以我猜是 77-78 年。是的。好的，我们可以查一下。
you're telling us about this a pivotal trip where you're taking your... So this would have been... Let's see. It's the same year the Apple 2 plus came out, so I'm guessing 77-78. Yeah. Okay, we could look it up.
70 年代末。我认为第一台 Apple 2 是 76 年左右，所以可能是 77 年。所以这是那之后的几年。所以我做了所有的研究，我正在寻找的两台顶级电脑是 Ohio
Late 70s. I think the first Apple 2 was like 76, so maybe 77. So this is a couple years after that. So I did all this research and my two top computers that I was looking at were the Ohio
Scientific Challenger 和 Exidy Sorcerer，我两者都不……是的。所以你们得去谷歌搜索一下，读者们。是的，那两台相当冷门。
Scientific Challenger and the Exitie Sorcerer and I neither would that Yeah So you'll have to Google those readers Yeah those two Pretty obscure
所以我决定买一台 Ohio Scientific Challenger，Wolf Camera 有卖 Ohio Scientific Challenger。所以我打算带着我的
So I settled on I was going to buy an Ohio Scientific Challenger and Wolf Camera carried the Ohio Scientific Challenger So I was going to take my
支票簿，在父母不知情的情况下，搭朋友的车去西雅图市中心买一台电脑。我想一旦我拥有了它，我父母就拿我没办法了，这就是计划。这就是我们所说的伏笔，伙计们。是的，一个初中/高中生的计划。所以我到了店里，推销员说，不，不，不，你想要 Apple 2 Plus，那是你想要的电脑。全新的，它会让你多花一点钱，比如掏空你的账户，但那是你想要的电脑。你知道，如果你今天买，我会额外赠送 16K 内存，所以你会有 32K 内存和一个卡带机。因为早期的 Apple 2，此时 Apple 2 可能有磁盘驱动器，但我肯定买不起磁盘驱动器，所以你加载
my checkbook and without my parents knowledge get a ride from my friend to downtown Seattle and buy a computer and I figured once I owned it there was nothing my parents could do about it so this was the plan that's what we call foreshadow folks yeah of a junior high high school kid so I get to the store and the salesperson is like no no no you want the Apple 2 plus that's the computer you want brand spanking new it's going to cost you a little more like train your account but that's the computer you want you know and if you buy it today like i'll throw in an extra 16k of ram so you'll have 32k of ram and a cassette deck because early apple twos at this point the apple two probably had a disc drive but i certainly couldn't afford the disc drive so the way you loaded
程序的方式通常只是插入 Apple 2 背面的音频盒式磁带，工作原理类似于调制解调器。所以他们会赠送一台松下卡带录音机，机壳顶部钻了一个洞，这样如果加载程序时出错，你就可以调整读写磁头。好吧。所以，你知道，我觉得这是世纪大交易。我觉得这是世纪大交易。所以在讲到那之前，再多一点背景。我父亲去过 1962 年西雅图世界博览会，
programs was often just an audio cassette tape that you plugged in to the back of the Apple 2 worked similar to a modem. And so they would throw in a Panasonic cassette recorder with a whole drill through the top of the case so you could adjust the rewrite heads if it was giving you errors trying to load your programs. Okay. So, you know, I'm thinking this is the deal of the century. I'm thinking this is the deal of the century. So a little bit more background here before I get to it. My dad had gone to the 1962 World Fair in Seattle,
那是在我出生之前。他看过一种平板电视的演示，我实际上查过。他说，那是一台电视，你直接挂在墙上。实际上那是背投电视，他们在世界博览会上没告诉你。但我父亲坚信，随时都会发布这种可以直接挂在墙上的平板电视。它们是彩色的，而且非常棒。所以，我们有一台 13 英寸的
which was a little before my time. And he had seen a demonstration of a flat TV, which I actually looked up. He was like, it was a TV, you just hang on your wall. And it was actually a rear projection, which they didn't tell you at the World TV. fair. But my dad was convinced that any day now, they were going to release these flat TVs that you could just hang on your wall. And they were color and they were amazing. And so, so we had a 13-inch
黑白电视，在他能买到 60 英寸挂墙电视之前，我们不会买新电视，他确实在他去世前大约两年买到了。但这花了很多时间。所以，我们家里实际上有两台小电视，一台 12 英寸和一台 13 英寸，黑白的。所以我买了这台 Apple 2，带回家放在卧室里，把我们的一台电视放在上面，插在后面，我有我的卡带机。现在我有我自己的电脑来写游戏了。还有我的卡带机。还有我的卡带机。还有我的卡带机。我父亲下班回家，经过我的房间，问，这是什么？我向他解释了我做了什么，他说，好吧，交易是这样的。
black-and-white TV and we were not getting a new TV until he could get, you know, a 60-inch hang-on-your-wall TV, which he did get probably like two years before he passed away. But it took a long time. So, so we had, we actually had two little, like a 12 inch and a 13 inch TV at home, black and white. And so I bought this Apple 2 and brought it home and set it up in my bedroom and took one of our TVs and put it on top and plugged it in the back and I had my cassette deck. And now I had my own computer to, to write games. And my deck. And my deck. And my deck. And my My dad came home from work and walked by my room and was like, what is this? And I explained to him what I had done, and he said, okay, here's the deal.
你可以留着它，但你必须把每一分钱都还给你的账户。这部分导致了我刚才讲的关于我送报纸的故事。老实说，这不是一个……我以为会是来自农村的，你知道，我以为会比那糟糕得多。只是说你必须把钱还上，这很合理。很合理。我想听听 Sean 为什么没有完成高中学业。好的。
You get to keep it, but you have to pay back every penny to your account. And so that partially leads to the story I was telling of me having a paper out. Honestly, it's not a... I thought it was going to be from like a rural, you know, I thought it was going to be way worse than that. Just saying you had to replace the money is pretty reasonable. Pretty reasonable. I want to hear why Sean didn't finish high school. Okay.
我相信你会讲到的。好的。所以，是的。我有这台电脑，我在大学大部分时间里都有它，你知道，在上面做了很多黑客行为。最终我附近的一个朋友，他爸爸买了一台 Apple II。我们在这些东西上做了各种硬件黑客。比如我们有一次造了一台绘图仪，我们没有步进电机。所以我们只是……
I'm sure you get to do it. Okay. So, yeah. So I had had this computer and I had it through most of college, you know, and did lots of hacks on it. And eventually a friend of mine in the neighborhood, his dad bought an Apple II. And we did all kind of hardware hacks on these things. Like we built a plodder at one point, which we didn't have stepper motors. So we did it by just...
什么是绘图仪？想象一下打印机，但带有笔和两个用于 X 和 Y 轴的电机，可以在纸上画画。所以就像“神奇画板”。好的。所以我们造了一个。我们没有步进电机，你可以控制它说，你知道，移动精确的距离。我们只有普通电机，但我们有电位器，所以我们可以反馈位置。所以控制电机并从电位器获得反馈来画画是一个软件挑战。所以我们做到了。
What is a plotter? Think printer, but with a pen and two motors for X and Y to draw a picture on a piece of paper. So etch a sketch. Okay. So we built one. We didn't have stepper motors, which you could control to say, you know, move exactly this distance. We just had regular motors, but we had potentiometers so we could feed back a position. And so it was a software challenge to control the motor and get feedback from the potentiometer to draw a picture on this thing. So we did that.
他爸爸有这台 Centronics IBM 打字机，我们找到了一些关于如何将打字机连接到电脑的文章，所以我们做到了，并把他那台，你知道，有点跳动的球形打字机变成了打印机。所以是的，这就是 MacHack 之前的 MacHack。我还有
his dad had this Centronics IBM typewriter and we found some article on how you could interface the typewriter to the computer so we did that and turned his you know kind of bouncing ball typewriter into a printer so yeah so this was the kind of MacHack before MacHack MacHack. I also
那个时期出现了很多 Apple II 软件，上面印着“由 Serpent 破解”，Serpent 是我的名字缩写，我的名字缩写是 SRP，所以是 S-R-P-E-N-T
there was a lot of Apple II software that appeared in this time frame that had stamped on it cracked by Serpent and Serpent was my initials are SRP, so it was S-R-P-E-N-T
所以 Serpent 就是我，而且……等等，这是互联网上众所周知的事实吗？我怀疑这不是互联网上众所周知的事实，但是的，有相当多的破解复制保护方案
so Serpent was me and... Wait, is this like a known fact on the Internet? I doubt it's a known fact on the Internet, but yeah, there was a fair amount of broken copy protection schemes
是我在那段时间破解的。哇。我可以回到那个故事，因为有一个关于它的故事与 Apple 有关。我们被抓住了很多故事。好的。
that I broke along the time. Wow. I could come back to that story because there's a story on that that connects to Apple. We've been caught so many stories. Okay.
那么我为什么跳过了高中最后一年？为什么我没有从高中毕业？我在高中表现还算不错。我当然不是全 A 学生，老实说，我在一些课程中通过使用电脑作弊来蒙混过关，这很有趣。我们学校有一个征税系统，
So why I skipped my senior year in high school? Why I didn't graduate from high school? So I did reasonably well in high school. I was certainly not a straight A student, and honestly, I cheated my way through some of the classes using computers for some of that cheating, which was fun. Our school had a levy system. which was basically the voters would vote on the school budget each year, or not each year, each few years.
基本上选民每年，或者每几年，会对学校预算进行投票。在我高三那年，有一项征税，所以选民们正在对学校预算进行投票。如果征税没有通过，我在高三那年将只有一门课程可以上。因为所有的 AP 课程都会被削减。所以就像一门公民课，我想是这样，一年只有一门课，而且
And going into my senior year, there was a levy, so the voters were voting on the school budget. And if the levy didn't pass, I would have exactly one course to take in my senior year. And because all the AP classes would be cut. and so it was like one civics class I think was it and like one quarter one class for the entire year and
征税确实通过了，但这并不重要。我姐姐当时比我大三岁，她正在西雅图大学读书，她说，你应该直接申请大学，直接去西雅图，你不需要高中毕业证。
the levy did pass but it didn't matter my sister at the time was she was three years older and she was going to Seattle University and she said well you should just apply to the university and just go to Seattle you didn't need a high school diploma
是的，这是我的回答。我想，我想，你完全疯了。我需要高中毕业证。不可能，不可能，不可能。但她一直缠着我。有一天，她带回了申请表。她说，填好寄出去就行了。所以我做了。
Yeah, which was my answer. And I thought, I thought, you're completely nuts. I need a high school diploma. There's no way, there's no way, there's no way. But she kept hounding me about it. And one day she, like, brought home the application forms. And she was like, just fill them out and send them off. And so I did.
我填好了，寄给了学校。我以为不会有什么结果。然后我接到了西雅图大学招生主任的电话，问，你为什么要申请？太早了。我解释了情况，主任说，好吧，我会为你安排一些教授面试，看看这是否合理。所以我去了西雅图，西雅图大学，和一些教授坐下来，接受了面试和盘问，通过了，并在没有高中毕业证、没有 GED 或任何同等学历的情况下被录取了。这就是我最终跳级且没有获得高中毕业证书的原因，每当我工作的每家大公司，也就是 Apple、Google 和 Adobe，当我提交工作申请时，总是有一行是，你在哪里高中毕业的？
I filled them off, and I sent them into the school. And I thought nothing would happen of it. And then I got a call from the dean of admissions at CLU that asked, why are you applying? It's too soon. I explained the situation, and the dean said, well, I'm going to set you up with some interviews with professors, and we'll see if this would make sense. And so I went into Seattle, Seattle University, and sat down with some professors and got interviewed and grilled and passed and got accepted without a high school diploma or no GED or any equivalent. So that's how I ended up skipping and not getting a high school graduation, which both when I, every major company I've worked for, which is Apple, Google, and Adobe, when, you know, I submit my application on your job application, there's always a line that's, you know, where did you graduate high school?
我列出我的大学学位，高中那一栏只写 NA（不适用）。通常不会跟进，但你可能有大学学位。不，不，每一次我都接到人力资源的电话说，呃，不，我们需要你高中毕业的学校。我说，我没有。这，
And I list my college degree and just write NA for not applicable for high school. typically don't follow up, but you've got the college degree probably. No, no, every single time I have gotten a call from HR going, uh, no, we need what high school you graduated from. And I'm like, I did not. This, the
有一次我提出了一个问题，当我开始时，我打算学习电气工程。我提到了硬件项目。我喜欢硬件。我姐姐是电气工程专业的。所以我打算学习电气工程，这就是我开始的地方。很快，我就决定了。
one time I posed a problem was when I started, I was going to go into electrical engineering. I mentioned hardware projects. I liked hardware. My sister was, was an electrical engineering major. So I was going to go into electrical engineering, so that's where I started. And very quickly, I decided.
那不适合我，我宁愿学习计算机科学，所以我打算转到华盛顿大学，但他们要求我有高中毕业证，而我没有。
that that was not for me and I would rather do computer science and so I was going to transfer to University of Washington but they required that I had a high school diploma and I did not
所以我不能转学，除非我退学并回高中读一年，所以那扇门关上了。所以我从电气工程转到了商业专业，简直是极其沮丧和无聊。
so I could not transfer unless I dropped out of college and went back to high school for a year so that closed one door so I switched from double E to a business major of all things was horribly frustrated and bored
然后我发现我们学校要开始一个计算机科学项目，所以我去找我的导师，问进入计算机科学项目需要什么，他们说，好吧，最好的办法可能是转到数学专业。
and then I found out that our school was going to start a computer science program so I went to my advisor and asked what it would take to get into the computer science program and they said well probably the best thing to do would be to switch to a math major
这会解决大部分要求，所以我转到了数学专业，那是数学专业，然后一旦他们开始计算机科学项目，我就转到了那个专业。所以我最后一年是计算机科学。你的学位是什么？
and that would get most of the requirements out of the way so I switched to a math major and it was a math major and then And as soon as they started the computer science program, I switched to that. So my last year was computer science. And what was your degree?
所以我获得了计算机科学学位，辅修数学，专业是人工智能，居然是人工智能。但这与今天的人工智能毫无相似之处。我们毕业班有 12 个人，是西雅图大学计算机科学的第一届毕业生。我们中有两个人实际上在 Adobe 工作。我正想说，你们保持联系吗，或者他们中有人……是的，所以让我们看看。
So I got a degree in computer science, a minor in math, and a specialty in AI, of all things. But it bears no resemblance to today's AI. And there were 12 of us in our graduating class, first graduating class from computer science out of Seattle University. two of us actually work at Adobe I was going to say do you keep in touch or have any of them gone on to Yeah So let's see
我和班里的三个人保持联系。所以，你知道，12 个人里有 4 个，我想我们互相认识。我想，我想我保持联系的一些人，
I keep in touch with Three from that class So You know Four of 12 I guess know each other I think I think Some of the people who I keep in touch with
和一些其他人保持联系。那是一个非常折衷的课程或班级。西雅图大学是一所天主教大学，耶稣会士，你知道，我们的一位同学曾经是耶稣会士，然后决定
Keep in touch with some of the other people It was a very eclectic course or a class Seattle University is a Catholic University Jesuit you know one of our classmates had had been a Jesuit and then decided
不再做耶稣会士，所以因为去西雅图，你？不，不，不。只是决定做点别的，最终进入了计算机科学项目，所以我们，让我们看看，我们有 12 个人的班级，我们有
not to be a Jesuit and so Because of going to Seattle, you? No, no, no. Had just just decided to do something else and it ended up in the computer science program and so we were let's see we had class of 12, we had
两个女性，我想是对的，两个。是的，两个女性。那些是，你知道，17% 比……它比……好。是的，我保持联系的人之一是来自新加坡的国际学生。
two women I think that's right, two Yeah, two women. Those are, you know, 17% is better than... It is better than... Yeah, one of the people who I keep in touch with was an international student from Singapore.
是的，所以这是一个相当混合的人群。我和他们中的一些人保持联系。我们有三位年轻的大学教授，他们开始了该项目，他们自己基本上是刚拿到博士学位，这是……他们集体决定，他们将用不同的编程语言教授每一门课程，但不教授编程语言。
Yeah, so it was quite the mix of people. I keep in touch with some of them. We had three young college professors who had started the program, who were basically freshly minted PhDs themselves, which was... they decided collectively that they would teach every course in a different programming language, but not teach the programming language.
所以你参加了课程，他们说，你知道，我们正在上一门图形学课程。它将用 LISP 教授。所以学习 LISP。所以，你知道，一堆语言，你知道，LISP，Forth，Prolog，C，Pascal。Ingres，这在当时可能是 SQL 的竞争对手，数据库语言，还有一种叫 Stardle 的东西，这是一种寄存器传输语言。所以只是得到了这种有趣而多样化的教育。我知道我们 12 个人中有几个很欣赏这一点。我认为大多数人没有，觉得它太奇怪了。
So you took the course and they said, you know, we're doing a course in graphics. It's going to be taught in LISP. And so learn LISP. So, you know, a bunch of languages, you know, LISP, 4th, Prologue, C, Pascal. Al Ingris, which was a pre-S, well, kind of competitor to SQL probably at the time, database language, something called Stardle, which was a register transfer language. So just got this interesting and diverse education. I know a couple of us of the 12 appreciated that. I think the majority did not, thought it was too weird.
但教授们也，我不认为他们当时有人结婚，所以我们会做一些事情，比如他们会说，好吧，我们明天有考试，人们在课堂上问问题，教授会说，好吧，为什么你们今晚不都到我的公寓来，我们再过一遍材料，涵盖它。
but the professors were also I don't think any of them were married at the time so we would do things like they would say well we've got an exam tomorrow and people were asking questions in class and the professor would say like well why don't you guys just all come over to my apartment this evening and we'll go through the material again and cover it
所以我们最终整晚和教授在他们的公寓里过材料。所以，那是一个了不起的经历，并奠定了基础。我在大学时结婚了。我妻子来自南加州，她爸爸，也就是我岳父，患有脑瘤。所以毕业后不久，我们就搬到了南加州，离她的家人近一些，我正在找工作，我在一家叫 Orange Micro 的小公司找到了一份工作，那是在阿纳海姆。想知道这什么时候会和其中一个故事联系起来。
and so we'd end up all night hanging with a professor in their apartment going through the material So, so that was, you know, an amazing experience and kind of set the ground work. And then I got married while I was in college. And my wife was from Southern California, and her dad, my father-in-law, had a brain tumor. And so kind of right after I graduated, we moved down to Southern California to be close to, her family and I was looking for jobs and I got a job at a little company called Orange Micro which was in Anaheim wondering when this was going to connect with one of the stories
是的，是的，让我惊讶的是，我从未在我的任何早期历史中讲过这个。是的，我当时在想。我的意思是，我们听过你这么多故事，我确实认为在某个时候你讲过一个关于在很多自由中长大的故事，你知道，父母，他们不是，你知道，哦，孩子们出去了，他们会回来，无论如何，在某个时候，我从来没有想过，等等，一个住在农村的人怎么会不像大多数人那样在某个大都市里，就像，哦，我们在某个学校旁边，那里有第一套电脑，无论如何，我们现在已经勾勒出来了，但我很惊讶，在我们进行的所有对话中，那从来没有被提及，而且这是一个非常独特的。有多少人能
yeah yeah so surprised me never covered this any of my early history yeah I was wondering that I mean we've heard so many of your stories and I do think at some point you told a story about growing up with like a lot of freedom and you know parents they're not you know oh the kids are out and they'll come back whatever at some point and at no point that i wonder wait how did some person living out rurally not in some metropolis like most of them it's like oh we were next to some school that had the first suite of computers and anyways we've now sketched but I'm surprised that uh in all the conversations we've had that's never come up um and it's a very unique. How many people can
说他们有一个父母在一家拥有第一批编程课程的公司工作，然后报名人数不够，所以孩子们就跟着去了，就像我刚才说的，这和其他关于……的故事没什么不同。所以我说我是那个教室里唯一的孩子，所以即使他们向家庭开放，我想可能还有一位配偶和我，我想，你知道，我记得那个班级非常稀疏，里面可能只有八个人。一个没有电脑的计算机课，是的。
say they had a parent that worked for a company that had one of the first programming courses and then not enough people signed up and so the kids came along like it's not dissimilar like I said earlier from other stories about. So I was saying I was the only kid in that classroom so even though they opened
所以我最终去了 Orange Micro，从那里我去了 MacHack 会议，我经常谈论这个，一个了不起的会议，我的好朋友组织并运营了它，并在那里举办了帽子比赛，他们来自 Apple。
it up to families I think there was maybe one other spouse and me and it was I think there were you know I remember that class being very sparsely populated there were maybe eight of us in there a computer class with no computers is yeah
Scott Boyd 和 Greg Marriott，我们前几天刚一起吃了午饭，仍然是非常好的朋友。当我在那里时，我接近了 Darren Adler，他现在是 Apple Safari 的负责人，他是 Apple 的回旋镖员工，他曾去 Magic Cap 工作，你可以查查那段历史。
so I ended up at Orange Micro and from there I went to MacHack Conference which I talk about a lot an amazing conference good friends of mine organized and ran that and ran the hat competition there and they were from Apple
他是那些工程师之一，我通过他写的杂志文章认识他，我在会议的第一天午餐时接近他，我有一个黑客想法，我知道如何写一部分，我想他会知道如何写另一部分，所以我问他是否想一起做。
Scott Boyd and Greg Marriott we just had lunch together the other day still very good friends and while I was there I approached Darren Adler he's now like head of safari at Apple he's a boomeringer at Apple he had gone and worked at a magic cap you look up the history of that
我们花了接下来大约 72 小时在 Mac Plus 上用 68K 汇编语言写代码，没有文档，只有一个调试器来弄清楚 API 调用，并让我们的黑客程序运行起来。在那之后大约两周，我接到了 Apple 的电话，问我是否想去面试。我想我们已经讲过我早期面试的一些故事了。
he's one of those engineers and I knew him for magazine articles that he wrote and I approached him at lunch kind of the first day of the conference and I had an idea for a hack and I knew how to write part of it and I thought he would know how to write the other part and so I asked if he wanted to work on it together
所以，是的，那变成了一份在 Apple 的工作，然后变成了一份在 Adobe、Google 的工作，又回到了 Adobe。这就是我的职业生涯。我想这可能是最后一个问题。因为它是，我的意思是，而且，在过去混乱的两个小时里，很多故事还没有讲。比如 Photoshop 4？
and we spent like the next 72 hours writing code on a Mac plus and 68K assembly language with no docs and just a debugger to figure out API calls and got our hack running and like two weeks after that I got a phone call from Apple asking if I want to go up and get an interview. And I think we've covered some of the stories of my early interview.
那是一个酒吧里的故事吗？那是，现在不是，但也许以后。有一个，是的，Bryce 和我昨晚在晚餐时聊到了那个，作为我们昨晚听到的 Photoshop 4 的故事，令人震惊。令人震惊。所以期待那个，听众。我想，是的，当你提到 MacHack，然后在我脑海深处，我知道你是 Smart Friends 的一员，那是一回事。有这些团体和会议。
So, yeah, that turned into a job at Apple, and that turned into a job at Adobe, Google, back to Adobe. And so that's how my career went. I guess maybe it's a final question. It's because it's, I mean, and also, too, across the chaotic last whatever two hours, a lot of stories haven't been told. Like, will the Photoshop 4?
这还存在吗？我觉得我的一部分，我觉得在每一个时间点，每个人都认为，啊，你知道，它不像以前那样了，但我确实觉得，你知道，你告诉我们，我不认为这是在我们录音时，而是，在我们开始录音之前，或者在录音之间，我应该说，你说因为你爸爸在波音工作，是前海军陆战队员，有很多汽车工作之类的，因为那是他感兴趣的，所以你曾经可以在 30 分钟内拆解某辆大众汽车的引擎并重新组装，我完全，如果汽车出了问题，
Is that an at the bar story? Is that, not right now, but maybe at a later day. There's a, yeah, Bryce and I were chatting about that as the Photoshop 4 story that we heard last night over dinner was astounding. Astounding. So look forward to that, listener. I guess, yeah, when I, when you bring up MacHack and then also two in the back of my head, I know that you were a part of smart friends and that was a thing. And there's these groups and conferences.
我们把它送到修理厂，我甚至不知道如果它不能开，怎么把它送到修理厂，无论如何，所以就像，这些，我觉得在 Bryce 和我们这一代程序员身上丢失了一些东西，我们不了解硬件，就像那些被抚养长大的人那样，无论如何，所以我只是，你对 2025 年的景观有什么看法，我不知道，有没有 MacHack 或 Smart 的等价物，我不认为有，你知道，这只是一个不同的时代，无论如何，我会，你知道，这只是一个不同的时代，无论如何。你可以发表你的想法。是的。
Does that exist? I feel like a part of me, and I feel like at every point, in time everyone thinks like ah you know it's just not like it used to be but i do feel like you know you were telling us i don't think this was while we were recording but uh before we started recording um or in between recordings i should say you were saying that because your dad was working at boeing and was a former marine there was a lot of car work and whatnot because that's what he was interested and so you at one point could disassemble the engine of some Volkswagen and like 30 minutes and like reassemble it and like i have absolutely if something goes wrong
你知道，MacHack 已经没了。Smart Friends 仍然存在。就是这样？是的，是的，是的。作为一个电子邮件列表？因为我知道有一个电子邮件列表。是的。是的，我们开过一次会议，但是的，它是一个电子邮件列表。
with the car we're taking it to the shop and uh i don't even know how to get it to the shop if it's not drivable and anyway so it's like uh these i feel like there's something lost on like bryce and our generation of programmers where we don't understand the hardware and like at the level that people that were brought up you know anyway so i just what does your take on 2025's the landscape of i don't know is there an equivalent to mackack or smart i don't think there is you know it's just a different time anyways i'll you know it's just a different time anyways You can give your thoughts. Yeah.
黑客会议，你可以，你可以谷歌一下。它还在进行。这是一个仅限受邀者的会议。我想今年是黑客会议的第 40 年。是的，所以那是，你知道，如果你想，好吧，你知道，Bill Atkins，最近去世了，他过去常参加，还有 Steve Wozniak 和 Don Knuth，所以，所以。一些知名人士参加，是的。所以，所以其中一些事情仍然存在。
You know, MacHack has gone. Smart Friends still exists. That's it? Yeah, yeah, yeah. As an email list? Because I know there's an email list. Yeah. Yeah, we had like one conference, but yeah, it's an email list.
你知道，MacHack 已经没了。Smart Friends 还在。就这些了吗？是的，是的，是的。作为一个邮件列表吗？因为我知道有个邮件列表。是的。是的，我们举办过一次会议，但确实，它现在就是一个邮件列表。
The Hackers Conference, which you can, you can like Google that. That's still going. It's an invite only conference. I think this year is the 40th year for hackers. Yeah, so that's, you know, if you want to, well, you know, Bill Atkins. who passed away recently used to attend and Steve Wozniak and Don Canuth and so, so. Some notable names attend, yeah. So, so some of these things still exist.
黑客大会（The Hackers Conference），你可以去谷歌搜一下。它还在继续。那是一个仅限受邀者参加的会议。我想今年是黑客大会举办的第 40 年。是的，所以，如果你想的话，嗯，你知道，最近去世的 Bill Atkins 过去常参加，还有 Steve Wozniak 和 Don Knuth 等等。一些知名人士会参加，是的。所以，其中一些活动仍然存在。
You know, it was interesting because living through all of this, I always felt like I was late to the party, right? I came into Photoshop during Photoshop 3. I joined Adobe, or I joined Apple right after Steve Jobs left, and kind of the original Mac team had left. And I joined Adobe during Photoshop 3 development, so I wasn't like the first person on Photoshop or any of that. You know, now that I'm, I'm, you know, 60 plus, it's, uh, I, now I feel like I was just fashionably late, right?
你知道，这很有趣，因为在经历这一切的过程中，我总觉得自己赶得太晚了，对吧？我是在Photoshop 3时期接触Photoshop的。我加入Adobe，或者说我是在史蒂夫·乔布斯离开后不久加入苹果的，当时最初的Mac团队已经离开了。我是在Photoshop 3开发期间加入Adobe的，所以我并不是Photoshop的第一批开发者之类的。你知道，现在我已经60多岁了，我感觉自己只是赶了个时髦的晚场，对吧？
Right, right, I was at the party. I just, just showed up fashionably late, you know, so if you're a, a young listener and getting in the industry and getting started and feeling like you're late to the party, you're not going to realize, you know, what you had and what was going on in that time frame until you can look back at it with some perspective. So that's how, that's kind of my, my perspective on that. And, you know, right now, it's like, you know, AI is brand new. Yeah, it's changing. Right? It's changing everything. And so there's a, there's a whole generation here that is
没错，没错，我确实参加了这场派对。我只是，只是赶了个时髦的晚场，你知道，所以如果你是一位年轻的听众，刚进入这个行业，刚开始起步，感觉自己赶得太晚了，你不会意识到，在那个时间段里你拥有什么，发生了什么，直到你能用一些视角回顾过去。所以这就是我对此的看法。而且，你知道，现在，人工智能是全新的。是的，它正在改变。对吧？它正在改变一切。所以这里有一整代人是
part of a new foundation right right a new technology that's changing the way society functions so
新基础的一部分，对吧，一种正在改变社会运作方式的新技术，所以
so you know embrace that right whatever role you play in that you're you're part of the party right? The last thing I'll add to that is that
所以你知道，拥抱它吧，无论你在其中扮演什么角色，你都是派对的一部分，对吧？最后我要补充的是
I felt the exact same way when I kind of quote unquote switch to computer science and I always I was chatting with Ben Dean once way years ago and I was telling him I feel like I just I'm so behind everybody because I'd spent six years in university and four years working at a non-tech
当我所谓的转行到计算机科学时，我也有完全一样的感觉。我多年前曾和本·迪恩聊天，我告诉他，我觉得自己落后于所有人，因为我在大学里待了六年，在非科技行业工作了四年，
technically I was writing code but I didn't know what I was doing. So I was like, I'm 10 years late. I'm 10 years behind. And I always, there's a scene from, I think it was the first Star Wars or the one with Con in it, the newer one with Chris Pine. You know, I mentioned the Star Trek, or sorry, it's Star Trek. You're going to get, I'm going to just edit it so nobody will know I messed up.
从技术上讲，我是在写代码，但我不知道自己在做什么。所以我当时想，我晚了10年。我落后了10年。我总是想起《星际迷航》里的一个场景，我想是克里斯·派恩主演的那部新版。你知道，我提到了《星际迷航》，抱歉，是《星际迷航》。你会，我会把它剪掉，这样就没人知道我搞砸了。
But yeah, the scene in Star Trek where they are like base jumping out of the spaceship and trying to land on some, like, tiny platform, and there's like three of them. Gentlemen, we're approaching the drop zone. We have one shot to land on that platform. They may have defenses, so pull your shoot as late as possible. Three, two, one. Remember, the Enterprise won't be able to beam you back until you can turn off that drill. Good luck.
但确实，在《星际迷航》中，他们像定点跳伞一样从飞船上跳下，试图降落在某个微小的平台上，当时有三个人。先生们，我们正在接近降落区。我们只有一次机会降落在那个平台上。他们可能有防御措施，所以尽可能晚地打开降落伞。三，二，一。记住，在你们关掉那个钻头之前，企业号无法把你们传送回来。祝你们好运。
Away team is entering the atmosphere, sir. 20,000 meters. Approaching the platform at 5,800 meters. Kurt Enterprise. This is the target, 5,000 meters. 4,600 meters from the platform. 4,500 meters to target. 4,000 meters.
外勤小组正在进入大气层，长官。20000米。在5800米处接近平台。柯特，企业号。这是目标，5000米。距离平台4600米。距离目标4500米。4000米。
3,000 bases. 2,000 meters. And that scene of like space jumping, I always felt like they space jumped and then like I jumped 30 seconds afterwards and so I was trying to as quickly as possible catch up with people. And then I remember telling this like analogy to Ben
3000米。2000米。那个太空跳伞的场景，我总觉得他们跳了，而我晚了30秒才跳，所以我一直在尽可能快地追赶别人。然后我记得把这个类比告诉了本，
and he was like, you've got that all wrong. Like sure, maybe you jumped out a little bit behind but the rate that you were accelerating and consuming stuff. Like most people aren't as curious and trying to learn everything. and so like you shot past them like a while ago and like you're you think you're behind but like if you consume as many you know C++ videos online and whatnot
他说，你完全搞错了。当然，也许你跳得晚了一点，但你加速和吸收知识的速度很快。大多数人不像你那样好奇，也不想学习一切。所以你很久以前就超过他们了，你以为自己落后了，但如果你在网上看了那么多C++视频之类的，
or whatever technology you're in and that reminds me of an Andrew in quote that he said that actually like it's actually quite easy to get ahead if you are willing to learn and read and do the work like a lot of people they'll ask you like how do I get into X or how do I do this thing
或者无论你从事什么技术领域，这让我想起吴恩达的一句话，他说实际上如果你愿意学习、阅读并付诸实践，想要领先其实很容易。很多人会问你，我该如何进入某个领域，或者我该如何做这件事，
and like he would always Andrew Ng would say we had this big course that was one of the biggest MOOCs of all time, and 100,000 people would start. And the number of people that would actually make it to the end is very few. And I've heard that echoed. There's a guy, Jeremy Howard. He runs a fast.a-a-a-I course, which is a free online machine learning data science thing.
吴恩达总是会说，我们曾经有一个大型课程，是有史以来最大的慕课（MOOC）之一，有10万人开始学习。但真正坚持到最后的人寥寥无几。我也听过类似的说法。有个叫杰里米·霍华德的人，他运营着fast.ai课程，这是一个免费的在线机器学习和数据科学课程。
And he runs them, I think, three or four times a year, and a few hundred people will sign up, and six will finish. And his advice, when people have just finished the course, it's free. It's not easy. It's a lot of work. But this idea that, yeah, that you're behind, anyways, you said that you know you're actually a part of the party it's it's just you're there it's not necessarily going to be uh you know free to be you know um but anyways it's uh it's great advice
他每年举办三四次，有几百人报名，但只有六个人能完成。当人们刚完成课程时，他的建议是，它是免费的，但并不容易，需要付出很多努力。但这种想法是，是的，你落后了，无论如何，你说过你实际上是派对的一部分，你就在那里，这不一定，你知道，是免费的，但无论如何，这是一个很好的建议。
anyways i'll hand the mic back to you if you want to say one last thing to till the next time i'm not sure i mean it's the tail end of uh 2025 so i don't know what conferences i'm going to in 2026 but uh hopefully we'll be able to do this again in person if not zoom's always a thing so So anyways, the final, final word for you, and then maybe we'll find a bite to eat or something or wander around. Yeah. I don't know that I have a final word, but, uh, yeah,
总之，如果你想在下次见面之前再说最后一句话，我会把麦克风交还给你。我不确定，我的意思是现在是2025年底，所以我不知道2026年会参加什么会议，但希望我们能再次面对面交流，如果不行，Zoom总是一个选择。总之，最后的话留给你，然后也许我们会找点吃的或者四处逛逛。是的。我不知道我还有什么最后的话要说，但是，是的，
I guess we're going to leave the cliffhanger on the Photoshop 4 story. Uh, yeah, that's about it. All right, there's another month and a half's worth of content. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is
我想我们要把Photoshop 4的故事留作悬念了。嗯，差不多就是这样。好了，还有一个月半的内容。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是
chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
充满信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。